[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 ou sommes le mercredi 15 janvier
voici les titres de cette édition
nouvelle journée d'action au 42e jour de
la grève contre la réforme des retraites
des mobilisations se sont tenues tout au
long de la journée dans le département
touchant plusieurs professions a besoin
le bretonneux elle vit ses derniers
jours la librairie lettres voisine va
fermer ses portes à la fin janvier faute
de repreneur 17 ans d'existence avec à
sa tête une gérante christine sauvage
son portrait à suivre et puis notre page
dédiée aux élections municipales à
trappes il est en lice pour un quatrième
mandat le maire sortant divers gauche
guy malandain et candidats l'élu a reçu
l'appui du parti présidentiel de la
république en marche et dans ce journal
on recevra également la fève 78 une
association par laquelle s'engage et des
étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin à la veille d'un nouveau
défilé interprofessionnelle à paris
contre la réforme des retraites une
journée de mobilisation dans les
yvelines plusieurs actions ont été
menées en différents endroits du
département
tout d'abord très tôt ce matin à bois
d'arcy vous le voyez sur ces images des
quatre heures est la plateforme
industrielle du courrier a été bloqué
par les facteurs et cheminots ce site du
groupe la poste s'occupe du traitement
des lettres dans les yvelines mais aussi
les hauts-de-seine et l'eure-et-loir la
distribution a donc été fortement
impactée aujourd'hui à rambouillet un
cortège s'est tenue à partir de 14
heures au départ de la caserne des
pompiers la manifestation qui a réuni
près de 200 personnes a fait le tour des
services publics de la ville
rambouillet où les professeurs du lycée
louis basse qu'en ont prévu d'occuper ce
soir leur établissement pour la nuit à
signaler également un rassemblement
d'enseignants cet après midi au rectorat
de versailles
et demain des actions sont également
prévues devant le siège de cmr à filiale
d'air france est elle en cours sur le
parvis et des mairies et de vélizy et de
meulan avant le départ pour paris pour
assister au défilé parisien
demain jeudi le réseau des transports
sera par ailleurs une nouvelle fois
perturber vos conditions de circulation
à retrouver sur les différents sites
ratp transilien également ski bus pour
la quatrième année consécutive yvelines
et hauts-de-seine ont célébré la
nouvelle année ensemble cérémonie des
voeux à la scène musicale de boulogne
billancourt ce mardi à 14 janvier
dans leurs discours les présidents
pierre bédier patrick devedjian ont loué
la décentralisation très critique en
revanche sur le modèle de métropole du
grand paris ils ont insisté sur les
bienfaits de la fusion voulue entre les
deux départements
patrick devedjian a annoncé le lancement
d'une concertation à partir du mois de
février sur le modèle et des assises de
la ruralité qui se sont déroulées dans
les yvelines écoutez ses explications au
micro de nicolas landry elle va
permettre de répondre à des tas de
questions d'entendre aussi les
suggestions dont entendent aussi les
critiques naturellement elle sera sous
forme d'internet en particulier avec un
site dédié à un dialogue continu qui
vaut mieux qu'on soit dans ce système de
concertation parce que bien entendu nous
sommes tellement convaincu du bienfait
de cette fusion que nous sommes tout à
fait disposés en discuter avec nos
concitoyens
le ministre le corps d'un qui est chargé
du dossier nous a clairement dit que il
reprendrait politiquement ce dossier
après les élections municipales
on est en train d'avancer techniquement
et tout montre me semble-t-il et les
propos qu'on a tenu ce soir vient de
conforter à ce sentiment c'est que il y
a un intérêt non seulement pour nos deux
départements et leurs habitants mais il
ya un intérêt pour la métropole du grand
paris les habitants des deux
départements pourront s'exprimer autour
de six thèmes cette plateforme citoyenne
sera accessible à partir du 6 février
on prend à présent la direction de
saint-germain-en-laye la cérémonie de
voeux de la commune s'est déroulée
samedi dernier au gymnase des
lavandières à cette occasion le maire
divers droite arnaud péricard a souhaité
à la population et l'année 2020 placée
sous le signe de l'optimisme au niveau
national et local
élu depuis 2010 est il a également
insisté sur la générosité entre les
habitants et la confiance entre
concitoyens
première invitée avec moi sur ce plateau
solène dubois bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
la déléguée territoriale de la fève 78
la faible c'est l'association de la
fondation étudiante pour la ville
elle intervient dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
grâce à à des étudiants engagés quels
sont les objectifs de l'association
alors
on a un double objectif d'abord un
objectif de promotion de l'engagement
chez les jeunes l'idée enfin le projet
de la fève c'est de favoriser
l'engagement dans un parmi les jeunes
fait en sorte que les étudiants
s'engagent dans les quartiers populaires
et de tisser du lien en fait entre
l'université et les quartiers
et donc du coup on propose en fait des
espaces d'engagement aux jeunes qui vont
monter des projets solidaires dans les
quartiers populaires donc l'autre
objectif 1 le double objectif c'est donc
de lutter contre les inégalités et de
lutter contre la relégation des
quartiers populaires à vous parler
d'engagement des étudiants ce sont en
l'occurrence la des étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines pas que où c'est principalement
ses étudiants alors principalement des
étudiants effectivement de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
donc effectivement c'est l'université
enfin l'université de versailles saint
quentin en yvelines et la plus grosse
faim universités des yvelines donc on a
développé nos actions autour en fait de
l'université aujourd'hui les étudiants
de l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines principalement
s'engage dans l'agglomération saint
quentin
donc principalement un trappe la
verrière la verrière pardon et l'encours
ils sont combien d'étudiants aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont engagés alors dans les
yvelines
on a soixante huit engagés actuellement
chaque année en fait on a environ
soixante dix à 80 étudiants qui
s'engagent à la fête en attendant c'est
à dire que le bénévolat connaît une
crise aujourd'hui est ce que les
associations telles que la voterons ont
facilement trouve facilement des
étudiants est ce que les étudiants
s'engagent assez facilement dans ses
causes solidaires
alors moi je dirais que oui la jeunesse
s'engage assez facilement après il faut
aller la chercher donc la fèvre
est présente sur les campus mène des
actions en fait de promo ce que je
disais tout à l'heure de promotion de
l'engagement alors sur les campus mais
pas seulement à la rencontre des jeunes
pour échanger les sensibiliser les
sensibiliser
la lutte contre les inégalités voilà
donc ça demande énormément de temps
d'investissement
et du temps salarié en fait pour aller
chercher des jeunes mais à partir du
moment où on a engagé on va dire la
conversation et que
beaucoup sont prêts ont finalement à
nous laisser leurs coordonnées à venir
en réunion d'information et puis ensuite
à s'engager du coup dans les actions
qu'on propose les actions développées
justement alors il ya de
l'accompagnement des jeunes en
difficulté scolaire ça ça se fait de
manière aussi bien individuelle que
collective
alors oui on a on a deux axes un accès
individuel donc les étudiants accompagne
deux heures par semaine
des enfants des adolescents
donc l'objectif c'est de tisser une
relation entre deux jeunes de jeunes qui
se serait pas forcément rencontré dans
un autre contexte et on a un axe aussi
collectif avec plusieurs ateliers dans
les établissements scolaires où nos
engagés vont monter alors dans les
collèges des à des ateliers qui vont
viser à éveiller la citoyenneté chez les
jeunes
our mobiliser aussi mais là du coup dans
des petits plutôt en s'appuyant sur des
petits collectifs et on a des ateliers
aussi en école primaire à la verrière
par exemple on a un atelier de médiation
par le jeu
donc
on vise aussi des enfants qui sont en
fragilité dans leur parcours éducatif et
attrapes
on vise des enfants qui ont des
fragilités dans l'expression langue
française et on utilise aussi le jeu
enfin des supports ludiques pour les
faire parler et s'exprimer plus
facilement français voilà voilà pour les
actions dernière chose est ce que vous
êtes à la recherche de bénévoles de
jeunes peut-être pour des missions de
service civique
aujourd'hui oui alors pour les missions
de service civique notre équipe est au
complet pour cette année par contre on
recherche encore des bénévoles
même si aujourd'hui en fait tous les
enfants qui nous ont été orientés sont
accompagnés on n'est qu'au mois de
janvier donc on aura encore certainement
des enfants accompagnés donc du coup
j'ai invite toutes celles et tous ceux
qui le souhaitent à nous rejoindre
le site affiche est encore plus
d'information merci solène dubois
déléguée territoriale et de la fève 78
cette nouvelle devrait ravir les parents
les nouveaux parents des
clayes-sous-bois une crèche privée a été
officiellement inauguré ce mardi en face
de la piscine salvador allende ouverte
depuis septembre la structure de 250 m²
permet d'accueillir 28 enfants dont 20
places sont réservées aux enfants de la
commune est les petits âgés de 10
semaines jusqu'à 4 ans sont prises en
charge par huit personnes en écoutent
les différentes réactions collectées au
micro de michael et demi d'eau à celui
là avant était un ancien centre médical
qui malheureusement fermé comme beaucoup
des centres médicaux année nous avons
souhaité absolument pour ce quartier qui
est un quartier important pour nous un
quartier vivant avoir une solution de
rechange
c'est notre 21e structures au sein du
département donc nous avons déjà les
liens forts avec le département c'est
notre première crèche aux
clayes-sous-bois mais nous avons eu
une collaboration exemplaire avec la
mairie est donc aujourd'hui on a la
chance vraiment d'être dans une
collaboration parfaite et un partenariat
qu'on espère duré très longtemps
une fermeture cette fois ci avec cette
mauvaise nouvelle pour les lecteurs de
voisins-le-bretonneux la librairie
lettres voisine va baisser le rideau
faute de repreneur un commerce ouvert
depuis 2003 avec une gérante à sa tête
christine sauvage son portrait signé par
manon varaldo derrière le comptoir de la
librairie lettres voisine située à
voisins le bretonneux et ouverte en mai
2003 se trouve christine sauvage sa
gérante
elle réside dans la ville nouvelle
depuis 1977
ça m'a permis quand même deux des
contacts avec un lectorat très
diversifié aussi bien des jeunes des
scolaires des tout petits
et puis des adultes et des gens aussi
très très bon lecteur très pointue dans
leurs demandes au fond de la boutique le
coin des enfants chers à la libraire
fans d'albums jeunesse d'enfants peuvent
regarder alors je me bats pour qu'aucun
livre soit par terre parce qu'un livre
c'est précieux
initialement en kiné christine sauvage
décide de s'orienter vers des études de
lettres elle a travaillé pendant dix ans
aux pavés du canal et du grand plaisir
elle est devenue enseignante dans un dut
métiers du livre elle apprenait la
constitution d'une librairie et la
comptabilité d'un commerce en fête pour
expliquer les choses à mes étudiants
c'était de créer moi-même ma librairie
dans un endroit où il y avait
pratiquement pas de librairie
mais moi mon objectif c'était de faire
cette cette librairie de proximité
christine sauvage et passionnée elle a
fait déplacer de nombreux auteurs elle
se souvient notamment de jumelles âgées
de 8 ans venue voir l'auteur perf dans
sa librairie et récemment
eh bien j'ai une de ces jeunes filles
maintenant qui est arrivé avec son papa
elle venait de se marier et elle me dit
vous avez toujours des guildes de bef
achetions bien sûr à son tour cette
jeune femme ne pourra pas venir chercher
un exemplaire pour son enfant suite à
des embûches lettres voisine
va fermer les difficultés sont venues
d'une part de nos fournisseurs comme il
faut le dire je vais au cours des années
mais remise diminué parce que je n'avais
pas un volume suffisant d'achat on a des
charges qui sont assez importante par
rapport à notre marge brute des gens qui
s'engagent dans la librairie staff
qu'ils n'auront pas des salaires
mirobolants mais de là à se retrouver
vraiment trop trop juste et ça a été un
des plus gros problème qui a été vu par
le repreneur en fait les représentants
en diminue la concurrence de la vente en
ligne progresse
la libraire déplorent les charges minime
pour les grands groupes
même avec notre syndicat des libraires
de france on n'a pas la force l'impact
nécessaire pour faire face à ce genre de
deux concurrents stenbeck parmi les onze
mille ouvrages dans la librairie des
cartons le déménagement est proche
c'est le coeur lourd qu'un chapitre se
termine pour christine sauvage je
regrette vraiment pour voisin que cette
librairie ferme parce que pendant
longtemps on a cru que ça allait
continuer et que d'autres prennent le
relais la librairie lettres voisine
fermera le 31 janvier à moins qu'un
repreneur se signalent depuis 1986 la
ville de jouy en josas possède la maison
de jeunes et léon blum la commune l'a
transformée en musée une fois par mois
des visites théâtralisées sont organisés
le reportage de mathilde et demi un
signal heureusement vous êtes là rien
n'a changé dans la maison de jeanne et
léon blum à part les locataires
c'est l'atelier de théâtre josas qui a
pris possession des lieux pour refaire
vivre l'endroit
l'ancien président du conseil du front
populaire et sa femme qui a oeuvré pour
l'éducation reprenne vie à jouy en josas
on a essayé d'être le plus précis
possible dans les tenues vestimentaires
dans les accessoires on s'est appuyé sur
des petites choses qu'on a appris par
exemple le fait que jeanne blum était
très mauvaise cuisinière des petites
choses comme ça de sa vie nous ont
permis de rendre beaucoup plus vivante
la visite léon blum
vivre à seulement cinq ans dans cette
maison quant à jeanne elle restera
trente deux ans après la mort de son
mari
jeanne et léon sous représenté par cinq
comédiens à des âges différents dans les
pièces de la maison
c'est vraiment une expérience très
plaisante se mettre dans la peau d'un
grand homme et d'un grand humaniste
comme lui
parfois c'est même presque exaltant puis
surtout comme on a eu la chance de le
jouer au moins une vingtaine de fois on
a eu vraiment le temps de faire ce
travail de bien entrer dans le
personnage
une visite qui emballe les spectateurs
et les replonge quelques années
auparavant quand la maison n'était pas
encore un musée je connaissais donc la
maison léon blum quand elle est encore
habité par jacques blue hawaii et dans
une boucherie qui avait au met et jeu
blum était cliente donc je suis venu qu
on avait sympathisé et elle m'avait fait
visiter toute la maison avant que ça
devienne un musée c'est beaucoup
beaucoup aimé sa visite théâtralisée
parce qu'en fait cela rend la visite
beaucoup plus vils ans on n'est pas dans
un musée mon lit en fait des pancartes
la troupe ateliers de théâtre du josas
se produit tous les premiers samedis du
mois de visites théâtralisées sont
organisées au 4 rue léon blum à jouy en
josas et le film je ne rêve que de vous
réalisé par laurent heynemann retrace la
vie du couple jeune et léon blum il sera
projeté le 28 fév 1er janvier à 20h à
jouy en josas en présence de l'équipe du
long métrage
avant de parler des élections
municipales un mot de ce sport le comité
des yvelines de badminton organisé une
animation en bad au féminin c'était
samedi dernier au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines une trentaine
de personnes étaient présentes au
programme de cet après midi et du fit
minton mélange de fitness et de
déplacement de badminton en musique les
propos sont recueillis par mathilde et
demi et on essaie de s'adresser
essentielle ment au public féminin parce
qu'on a un petit déficit dans cette ce
type de public et voilà on voudrait
essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
de plus d'adhérentes féminine dans au
badminton
on voulait essayer aussi en même temps
de
de faire découvrir la pratique du
badminton en fait de faire découvrir
d'autres pratiques parce que le
badminton évolué notamment chez
essentiellement pour les filles mais
aussi pour les garçons du coup qu'ils
sont
des activités de feed minton et de zoom
bad donc qui associe un peu le fitness
ou la zumba donc à des mouvements de
bègles hinton puisque dans le back in
town ya beaucoup de déplacements de pas
chassés
deux sauts de choses comme ça
[Musique]
la fin de ce journal avec la partie
dédiée aux élections municipales d'abord
un mot du scrutin à versailles la liste
ensemble vivons versailles a été
officialisée jeudi dernier porté par
anne france simon cadres dans la finance
elle n'a pas encore reçu l'investiture
officielle de la république en marche
malgré le soutien du député lrm didier
baichère la commission nationale
d'investiture qui pourrait soutenir le
maire sortant françois de mazières
ce dernier ayant écarté écarté
françois-xavier bellamy aujourd'hui à
député européen l air côté propositions
en france il en a déjà annoncé vouloir
installer une maison de l'emploi et des
métiers à la place de l'ancienne poste
centrale guy malandain bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur vous êtes le maire sortant
divers gauche de trappes élu depuis 2001
dans la ville vous serez candidat pour
un quatrième mandat aux élections
municipales premier tour je le rappelle
le 15 mars prochain on précise que vous
avez 82 ans pourquoi être candidat pour
un nouveau mandat est d'abord là je ne
rompt pas ce qui compte c'est à mon avis
c'est la fois l'expérience
et puis le dévouement au service des
habitants et donc on va laisser la date
de naissance de côté pour l'instant ça
ça va très bien excellent engagement qui
commencent à avancer alors moi je suis
candidat avec un certain nombre de mes
amis d'autres sont partis peu importe ce
n'est pas sale objet parce que il ya
d'abord trappe et chacun le sait en tout
cas les habitants de trappes le savent
ils acceptent tout y est passé
c'est ma passion c'est voilà je suis
tous les jours tous les jours pendant de
nombreuses heures au service des
habitants
parce que il ya dans cette ville des
éléments qu'on trouve pas york y sont
des éléments de de fraternité de
rencontre des découpes de connaissances
toutes les semaines je vais au marché
bonjour comment ça va si j'y vais pas en
étant est pas venu qu'est ce qui s'est
passé bref un système de relations
humaines qui ne changent pas les choix
politiques on y viendra peut-être tout à
l'heure mais qui est pour moi quelque
chose de fondamental on n'est pas élu à
trappes vu la population qui est
exceptionnel je le dis contrairement à
ce qu'on raconte un peu partout
n'importe quoi merritt simplement que
les élus soit humainement attaché à un
travail ensemble à une promotion de la
ville et et à lui continué a dû
construire l'avenir qu'on essaie de
bâtir avec les habitants quelquefois et
difficultés mais quelquefois aussi avec
avait beaucoup de plaisir de ténacité et
de réussite et vous précisiez il ya un
an au moment de l'annoncé de votre
candidature que voilà si vous êtes réélu
vous n'irez pas forcément au bout de ce
mandat est ce que c'est toujours vrai
aujourd'hui c'est si vous êtes élu vous
ne ferez pas forcément les six ans le
mandat on verra je dis souvent personne
ne sait qui est ce qui se passera demain
temps tant que je serai en forme
physique et intellectuelle et et qu' un
certain nombre de chantiers ne seront
pas terminés je veux pas mettre du temps
parce que je n'en sais rien je serai
présent dans ma fonction
alors pour cette candidature vous avez
reçu le soutien du parti présidentiel de
la république en marche est ce que ça
veut dire votre liste portera cette
couleur vous allez non au contraire
regardez votre indépendance et d'un
homme de gauche vous êtes un ancien
j'exprime aussi à l'histoire
c'est pourquoi le le
notre député
nadia et et à la république au mans je
peux c'est aussi je veux pas l'ennuyer
avec ses propos un mais c'est aussi
quelqu'un de trappes ses parents
habitent toujours trappe et caetera et
avec un certain nombre de ses 16 ans
nombre de milices ils ont analysé ce
qu'on faisait alors qu'elle tient dire
assez prétentieux et nous voulons c'est
une réalité ils sont venus analyser ce
qu'on faisait et hill on le pensait que
soutenir l'action éducative l'action
sociale l'action sportive l'action
culturelle le développement et dans la
rénovation urbaine qui a été fait en une
étape et qui va recommencer maintenant
bref que toute cette dynamique là
méritait un soutien et convenait et là
je le dis tout clair et convenait bien
la députée donc je suis une sensibilité
à gauche en tout cas moi je vais pas
changer les opinions je suis entré en
politique à gauche et j'ai travaillé
pendant des années je continuerai à le
faire et jean pierre chevènement il
s'est agit pas changé d'avis je n'ai pas
changé d'orientation nos choix restent
les mêmes mais il se fait que de temps
en temps le ce mouvement politique a
soutenu quelques maires de gauche pour
ce qu'ils faisaient et tant que ben
voila j'ai hérité de ce soutien voilà
alors pas de nom de liste encore arrêté
est ce que le contenu en tout cas la
liste est totalement athée ce que les
membres sont sont totalement connue elle
est au complet réalise la plupart des
des membres sont des gens connus oui et
dont certains vont étonner
d'autres si je puis dire où on a
consulté les autres équipes moitié
moitié entre anciens moitié nouveaux
seins si je puis dire des iphone ça va
renouveler avec des personnalités qui
sont dans l'esprit que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on est engagé pour les habitants
pour la ville et comme jeu
dans ma lettre d'intention nous sommes
il n'y a pas de nom de liste mais nous
sommes la gauche qui fait mes bras
gauche qui partira tout de même divisée
attrape avec cette candidature
davos ralliera ps qui a parlé ce que
l'alternance
cela ne m'intéresse pas et ne fait pas
partie il ya deux côtés c'est dur partie
2 de mes comportements folie politique
et bennoo je dis toujours il ya la
gauche qui fait on peut prouver ce qu'on
a fait 1 et puis la gauche qui cause et
qui promet pas si les gens croient aux
promesses passées leurs affaires vous
êtes à la tête de la municipalité je
disais tout à l'heure depuis 2001 quel
bilan vous dresser sur cette dernière
mandature celle qui s'est déroulée de
2014 à 2020
oui deux éléments essentiels pour faire
en répertoire ou liste à la prévert
comment bien simplement pour pour moi
l'équipe a obtenu 2,2 deux éléments
positifs
je répète toujours chacun à son jugement
quand on n'a rien fait c'est facile de
juger les autres c'est d'abord la
poussée éducative avec notre projet
éducatif de territoire on viendrait le
18 mai dernier d'être d'être nommé ans
avec le label cité éducative
il ya des progrès et scolaires culturels
etc tous les acteurs de manière
transversale
bien sûr le le passage de notre école de
musique en conservatoire ça veut dire
que les diplômes des des personnes dans
ce dans cette école dans ce
conservatoire maintenant sont une valeur
une valeur nationale
et puis enfin pour terminer ne pas être
trop long dessus et enfin le démarrage
des travaux sur la nationale 10 le mur
que vous avez dit cela sera lui seront
mois d'avril homogène on met en place à
cause dit on sait les services et les
entreprises nationales de l'équipement
au met en place le pont provisoire qui
va remplacer le pos le pont qui achètent
ça veut dire elle se projette on parle
depuis des dizaines dizaine d'années ça
y est les parties en vingt ans vingt ans
de boulot on va voir dans l'est c'est
parti ces partis officiellement partie
et après on fait le rond-point rd 912
nationale 10 autres anges et la
rénovation urbaine vous en parliez
est-ce que ça va se poursuivre il ya eu
à la ville a profondément changé miner
le premier projet 350 millions d'euros
d'investissements plus une
transformation de la ville enfin on peut
ne pas être d'accord ne peut pas dire
que la ville n'a pas changé et puis là
nous sommes en train de terminer les
négociations avec l agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine pour le deuxième
contrat de rénovation urbaine qui sera
beaucoup moins important que le premier
un thème qui revient constamment attrape
c'est la sécurité notamment la la
question de la radicalisation avec des
dizaines de départs vers la syrie est ce
qu'un maire a les moyens et ce qu'il a
le devoir d'agir et ce qu'il a les
moyens d'agir face à ce phénomène
alors deux réponses là dessus oui nous
avons vécu un moment douloureux
intensifs
et qui s'est stoppée et nous avons mis
en place avec les services compétents de
l'état et ses jeux ça ne se fait pas
oui en mer et ne peut pas regarder ça
sans bouger nous avons mis sur pied en
place différents outils bien le mot
convient peut-être pas enfin différents
éléments de travail pour arrêter ces ses
départs vers la violence la misère et
l'inhumanité et là nous sommes je moi je
donne les renseignements qu'on me donne
voilà nous sommes là maintenant revenu
en situation paisible par rapport à la
radicalisation à outrance qu'on a connu
un moment
dernière chose que vous avez des rendez
vous de campagne des rendez-vous prévu
avec la population les trappistes dans
les projets l'année prochaine ça tu as
tu du cgri de toute une série de
réunions à partir du 15 février oui 15
février
merci à guy malandain 27 le maire divers
gauche sortant de trappes également vice
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et vous serez
candidat pour un quatrième mandat dans
la commune se sont officiellement
déclarés aussi pour le scrutin
othman nasri qui est conseiller
municipal d'opposition et qui mènera la
liste engagement trappe citoyens et
l'adjoint au maire ali rabais à la tête
de la liste pour que tu rappes respire
et puis un autre maire sortant candidat
raphaël cognait briguera un second
mandat à mantes-la-jolie l'élu les
républicains qui avaient pris à la suite
ça de michel vialay en 2017 est devenu
député conduira la liste montrent unis
trois axes pour son programme un
traitement équitable des quartiers le
logement est aussi la modération fiscale
face à lui pour le moment marque jamais
candidat et du parti communiste
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi dans un instant ne
manquez pas le 7-8 société comment
lutter contre l'effet que new c'est la
question qui est posée ce soir belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]